combien de taper show de boeuf un truc
séquence émotion oui surtout thomas
murray set mais c'est ça j'ai compté 7
milliards à mx ya noël avait mis là ça
fait 8 merde alors il ya d'ixia manon
elsa jullien on a préparé une petite
confidence est royale à julie jus poche
on n'a pas plus que les belles sinon
dépasser
[Musique]
au bar
cette source
bezos
alors aujourd'hui demander où donc avec
alsace était que pour l'émission
d'accord avec toi tu paies chose pour
les émissions c'est aussi la belle
mourinho est ce que tu peux pas son
cartable et me tiens j'ai pas eu le
feeling après j'ai lu avec julia est là
depuis peu je suis célibataire
c'est bien de faire un thé mais elle est
tombée amoureuse et j'ai pas voulu le
blesser c est vrai je les fréquente et
qui se trouve là
julia ouais elle était amoureuse elle
s'attache à moi j'ai pas voulu faire un
passage page pas encore fait ont
souffert tu vois ce que tu veux dire
prends ton temps on tourne maintenant
était sûr et sur un délire en ce moment
tu es sur un bail quoi ouais je m'amuse
profitons prend pas la presse est un
bâtard et à droite la gauche au calme
toi quand même nom mais alors qu'ici on
a des machines sur ses rêves si les
hommes voiture à ce moment les békés
mensonge en battant paga je vais te dire
l'album ce que tu veux bien entendu
puisqu'il n'ya pas de mal ils s'engagent
ensemble quelques pas de la gare tu veux
faire un pogo et qu'elle va tuer
le triangle fou quand même le triangle
de yang le fond je suis célibataire
c'est vrai avant centre et des collègues
alors un jeu te présenterait des
collègues et l'autre il parle aux
diffuseurs des amis sont gays comme je
présenterai la voie non mais les doulas
vous êtes complètement le jannou là et
au cerveau ce qu'on appelle du
célibataire dames aussi que tu gères
équilibre là seront de demandes et on se
connaît déjà la cour de dom a trop de
demandes c'est normal une belle fille
comme ça c'est normal c'est un bon
mariage sur une journée vient de se
marier c'est pour la vie le mariage je
trouve elle veut se marier à lesparre la
veille a pris peu après toi avec la wii
avec grand plaisir avec grand plaisir
il est prince a offert avec toute
addiction
ah ouais pourquoi indique sais pas où tu
t'es tu t'énerves et même un jour acadie
tiens parce que c'est à la chine est un
mec ou je sais pas quoi
il ya un délire où elle s'est fait
draguer par un mec regard addiction bien
avant du circuit vente dans le jeu de
séduction de kevin hell sommes par
contre le monde qui me fait ça me met
hors de moi je peux m'énerver j'ai envie
de tout casser
copé
j'étais là
grosse
c'est la production qui fait tout seul
non franchement déjà amoureux font de
ouf la dic ça je fais tatouer a dit chan
non c'est pas vrai
la bataille à dire que c'est un nom de
voiture arrive voilà c'est pas pour me
marier avec elle c est là bas mais je me
suis vite on fait vraiment rien vous
êtes marié les deux je veux plus
l'officialiser en france j'ai pas voulu
le faire et d'or si je n'ai pas fait et
oui vous êtes mario à miami non non
thaïlande c'est la taille on est comme
moi j'avais dans la durée le mariage
commence à combien de temps ça va durer
mais je suis une journée
[Applaudissements]
avec moins d'éléments démarré alors oui
mais tu t'es marié des divorcés remariés
deux ans et demi non nouveau casque mais
l'essentiel est là pour tester la relève
se réclame et était encore amoureux
d'elle ou pas si ce fameux jardin si je
peux me permettre
tu perds je te sens encore un peu
accroché non et je connais les rapports
humains s'était juré non c'est marrant
moi aussi à toi aussi je sois pas au
sens non dans le sahara et avec un bon
moment mais c'est fini là c'est fini
elle a un mec elle oui à templeuve et
nan nan parce qu'ils me voient je dis
moi la vérité à moi m'énerve ce qu'elle
est partie avec les number jack sa
lumber jack cédé 19 bref elle est du
coup elle est partie donc notre carrière
musicale et services à usage
professionnel égard qu elle aussi l'art
est cartonné cette épreuve je le sent et
se sont touchés oui oui on le sent
touché